[Applause]
we're not here to judge anybody we want
to handle this with love right you want
to tell him how his drug abuse has hurt
you and he hurt himself
okay Harold what time did you tell him
to be here five o'clock but he's always
late no he'll be here in three two one
this is a five o'clock free crack
giveaway
don't tell anybody I can
[Music]
this week Tyrone gets invited to an
intervention oh hey okay Tyrone do you
know why your man I was from crack crack
hey Tyrone we are not giving crack away
today
Oh what time is it it's five o'clock
then I missed the five o'clock free
crack giveaway head-on these are your
friends here and they have something
they'd like to say to you have a drink
okay
okay Tyrone I'm what is known as an
intervention counselor oh and these
people would like to talk to you about
your drug use
huh come on we better take our work out
okay Rhonda Rhonda Bridgewater's this is
ridiculous what is going on in here we
got crack at the end Tyrone you know I
love you but I feel like drugs is
hurting you and that hurting me Tyrone I
was very hurt that you carjacked me that
time I don't know look the police found
two three hours later in my car asleep
found crack
that's impossible Rhonda hackney sleep
daddy's little boy okay I do that wrong
Tyrone we opened our home to you you let
your addiction lead you to abuse our
trust Oh Jeanie
look it's me talking I would never hurt
you don't play dumb with us Tyrone I
remember the whole speech
I just need $200 I take these rest day
classes
and I'm back on my feet baby I'm serious
Rob it's me babies Tyrone I studied my
ass off for that real estate test we're
off to my mother's back son evening the
number is on the fridge if you need
anything
Parrish Matisse and was a certified real
estate agent good for you Tyrone yeah
damn right good for him he sold our
house and kept the money four hundred
and fifty thousand dollars where's the
money Tyrone he spent it on a party took
out an ad for it the paper heart attack
I'll give you a restraining order gives
you Harold all right Carol I'm here
because I love you what have you learned
so much Harold wanna be fired from the
post office huh do you know how many
people on your route complain of
receiving open mail seven 136 Tyrone and
then there was the incident with the
powder
[Applause]
[Music]
Benjen everybody we only look out for
any envelopes mark Senator Tom Daschle
or Tom Brokaw might contain anthrax
little white powder and if it fell into
the wrong hands it could be big trouble
I got anthrax mr. bomb baby sixty bucks
if that man hadn't turned you in it
would have been a disaster y'all act
like crack is so bad
well like the Good Book says let he who
is without saying throwing the first
rock and I shout SMO give it basically
Tyrone we would like you to check into
rehabilitation immediately all right
okay fine fine do you know what I need
to get better y'all right but first step
is first I need to go to the bathroom
and then I'm on my way to recovery Rondo
and that was me Rhonda go to the
bathroom okay I've got it from here
thank you
I'll be right out oh oh why they say no
windows in here
[Laughter]
[Applause]
Oh
we have a very special surprise today
let's hear it for Tyrone back thank you
very much teacher it is truly an honor
and a privilege for me to be here upon
her school or whatever your school is
called today I say it's a privilege
because it's a violation of my parole to
be around children oh hello little boys
and little girl today
started doing drugs when I was little
just like you thought me and my friends
would go home and smoke marijuana at
school do you say marijuana sometimes
dipped in embalming fluid and me and my
friends would laughing giggling eat all
the cookies it was terrible terrible I
can definitely say he was the absolute
worst anti-drug speaker in the history
of drugs then I upgraded to a little
drug how acid very inexpensive in
even young children could have he
basically told them where and how to buy
the stuff we know we can sneak into our
mama's room when she's sleeping and take
five ten twenty dollars out of purse run
on down to third Street catch the bus
downtown and meet latin-american fellow
named Martinez we know that Martinez
stuff is the palm drugs oh you might be
asking well tell you you'd imagine
Marcus what you think that is some kind
of crime no take the cap off and snip it
[Applause]
these little ones are ten and eleven
years old you you know the dog food
tastes like Delia it pays dislike it
smells delicious
I thought the worst was over I was
mistaken bad children was the first
[Applause]
[Music]
lovely and moving a graphic story
you welcome teach a bitch penis but
that's all right
can I get cash for this I've got some
errands to run
and I don't think I'm gonna make the
bank thank you kids come back my name's
Tyrone Ricky
sometimes in this pursuit crack leaves
me tired and depleted but man cocaine
comes in the delicious shake bread balls
it gives me way
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
people steal booze they're winos me hey
I got this suit
we have a crack head lifting up the bus
laughs this dress
Hecky redbones excuse me
jailer pardon me but I have a red balls
please
we're both okay to the cave
for this my name is Jeff I'm a computer
programmer from Redondo Beach and I
refuse to lose my name is Rita I'm from
Idaho but trust me I know couch potato
I'm Anne I'm from Boston I promised my
mom I wasn't going to embarrass her here
tonight and I get a pig testicle bear
with all the fixings got play to win
[Music]
here is your first stun we each have to
lie in his coffin covered with worms and
bugs the three of you that can last the
longest move on to the next round Rita
you're up first
climb on in all right we're gonna have
to add a few more to the mix
got what I'm trying to call in my mouth
one minute and 42 seconds let me just
help you get some more baby look at him
spreading hey spreading 5 minutes and 42
seconds and it's all up to you
lie down
[Applause]
that was WOW all right ty
I'm gonna tell you something about me
Joe Rogan that you might not know I
smoked wax
[Applause]
you did it Tyrone you shattered Jeff's
time you come on out leaving my
newspaper I haven't had a chance to
steal and read for so long
technically he's staying there as long
as you want
you know what taking that
could you all symbolize please feel
welcome
all right it's time for your next
challenge walking on hot coals some of
these coals burn at over a thousand
degrees a few people that can spend the
most time in those coals will advance
all right Rita you're up first
ready do this go eight seconds go Tosh
seven seconds we didn't get beat your
time congratulations you advance
automatically Tyrone it's up to you now
all you have to do is be Jeff's time of
seven seconds and you will move on to
the next round and be that much closer
to $50,000 Oh take your shoes off let's
do it
[Applause]
is it okay if I smell somebody cooking
hazel steaks can't fish crab apples hey
how are you okay oh you you you want you
beat Jeff's time you advance the next
round
hmm
[Applause]
all right Rita Tyrone here is your final
stunt each one of these platters
contains over 80 pounds of elk penis and
a light cream test and a sauce it's
topped off with diced pig bladder for
dessert we have horse hooves whoever can
eat the most is $50,000 go hurry up girl
I'm gonna do my turn
we have seen something juicers oh I
can't do this
you sure all right I'm sorry
you were eliminated all right ty it's up
to you all you have to do is eat a
little bit and you're the Tyrone you are
our champion congratulations and
evidently fear is not a factor for you
I'm trying to district bingo Tim like
his mom's
[Music]
change I have talent I could finally
make an honest woman out of you give you
that rock you always had your own
[Applause]
first they I hate the space
[Music]
[Applause]
you